lui
m
non
c'est quoi cette musique d'église et on
est là pour parler hip hop aujourd'hui
ça c'est mieux op 45 est une association
du loiret qui représente l'art des
danses urbaines ce collectif de danseurs
fait la fierté de l'agglomération au
plus haut niveau et ce depuis plusieurs
années une bonne occasion pour moi
d'évaluer mon niveau de danse
au niveau de danse et ne souplesse aussi
visible
[Musique]
j'ai vu tout va devoir compter un peu
aussi à l'histoire la haute et 45 c'est
vraiment toi qui à l'origine de tous de
l'association exactement ça donc ça
remonte un peu près à 15 ans donc c'est
à l'époque dans ma jeunesse donc j'étais
professeur de danse hip hop si on vous
avait dit il ya 15 ans lorsque vous
démarriez cette aventure de l'opé 45 que
le hip hop tendre et une telle envergure
est ce que vous l'auriez cru ce que le
hip hop est partout désormais ce qu'il
faut vraiment prendre conscience c'est
que le hip hop c'est une culture
organique c'est à dire qu'elle se
nourrit toujours des influences afro
électro et grandit tout le temps et donc
du coup elle se renouvelle tout le temps
donc l ai jamais obsolète et coq tu
côtoies cette culture souvent tu tombes
fans et tu es tu la gardes et tu grandis
avec l'origine y en a qui dans le coup
aujourd'hui là donc on à annie jesse et
elodie chant touré par des vrais pros on
à elodie qui
qui maîtrise aussi les danses afro c'est
ça alors oui il paraît que mon bassin
est raide mon cousin ce qu'on me dit on
va ça il est raide
ça va ça c'est pas mal là au moins il ya
un pas de danse qui me fascine dans la
danse afro cessez le feu qui fait comme
ça là comme c'est plus que moi je suis
là c'est cela que je
ali alliés lors quelle est ta spécialité
ali a reçu plus dans leur lit on ce qui
est fait avec des touches féminines donc
toujours du lot avec les petites touffes
de cheveux
noirs habitués un truc que je vais
essayer de faire montrer mon l'instinct
féminin c'est horrible aucun animal donc
par exemple tu allais juste
donc oui
je sais ce qui va décaler vu sa jambe
droite et est
oui
alors jesse as tu trouvé quelques signes
et quelques pas de danse sur les phrases
suivantes ne vient pas de la cité mais
le but est bon j'admets de marly-gomont
qu'est ce que tu nous as trouvé pour
danser les représenter c'est ces paroles
normalement sur la musique ça donnerait
tu chantes ou pas ouais pam pam pam pam
pam vient pas de la cité mais le beat
est bon je viens pas de paname et de
marly gomont
hockey ces travaux
allaient musique ou pas là cadeau pour
vous les gens du centre val de loire
curly se ferait
pas
la droite se chiffrer par on déplacerait
plateau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]